Pants on Fire. Pants on Fire.
It is officially Tell a Lie Day.
Or is it?
Historically, George Washington
hated this holiday,
but Nixon loved it.
So to celebrate this fib fest,
comedians, please give me
as many of the lies
you've told as possible
in 60 seconds.
-Affion.
-Nah, girl, you ain't get fat.
That's just extra love meat.
All right. I'll give you points.
Jamar.
Uh, no, I smoke weed
for medicinal purposes.
Points. Tiffany.
Yes, yes, I am Angela Bassett.
Points. Affion.
Ma'am, there's no such thing
as an ugly baby.
Your baby looks like a young
Steve Buscemi in the face.
Points.
Points. Jamar.
Uh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
When I get rich,
-I'm-a give back
to the community. Yeah. -Points.
Tiffany. Tiffany.
Ooh, Chris, it's so big.
It hurts.
(cheering and applause)
Hey. You know what...
Okay.
I'm gonna give you points,
and I'm also pissed
that no one ev... has attempted
to use that lie.
Jamar.
Man, I'd never wear a dress
in a movie.
Points. Tiffany.
Yes, I'm pregnant by you, Chris,
and you gonna pay
this child support.
-Stop playing games. It's
your baby. -All right, points.
Points. Points.
I'm sorry.
I just can't keep
my big old dick in my pants!
-It's just so big, it's hard
to contain it. -Chris! Chris!
It's just hard to contain it!
(cheering and applause)
Aah!